62 percent of americans say they have
political views they're afraid to share
afraid to share let's take a look at
this a new cato national survey finds
that self-censorship is on the rise in
the u.s remember this is in july of
2020.
nearly two-thirds 62 percent of
americans say the political climate
these days prevents them from saying
things they believe because others might
find them offensive
how sad if you scroll down a little more
something interesting
strong liberals stand out however as the
only political group shocking tyler who
feel they can express themselves
now we laugh but why is that
there's a reason for that the reason is
that strong liberals and by the way it's
not the same the article points out
centrist liberals do not fall into that
category centrist liberals are more
afraid to speak their mind the reason
strong liberals feel comfortable is
because when liberals come out
strong liberals reliable liberals
they're usually backed in their opinions
by big establishment
organizations nike
hollywood
an award show
disney you know so they feel supported
they feel like i've got they're not
coming out like one person out there hey
by the way it's not like that social
media influencers you know how this
works it's like almost like you know
silicon valley all of these bigs
come out and usually endorse those
talking points so that's why strong
liberals typically feel comfortable
because they don't feel alone
they don't feel alone they feel very
much supported by very powerful groups
when they speak their minds
but everyone else do you want to live in
a world where people are afraid to say
how they feel
i don't
i want to hear if tyler feels
differently from me and jumps in and
says hey you know what i don't think he
is well he knows that he's welcome to do
that in this space jorge will mic you
anyone really i i welcome that that
shows me you're thinking hey you're
listening to what i'm saying so thank
you
you've got at least open ears and
secondly
you're thinking for yourself
amazing i wouldn't ex if you agreed with
me every step of the way that's called a
robot i don't need a robot that does me
no good you know i hate ai
and there's more
there's more on this that i'm scared of
i kept looking once i started and i
found that from the cato institute i
went to yougov
this is also from 2020. this has also
gotten worse look at this
americans are less likely to have
friends of very different political
opinions compared to 2016. they went
back to 2016. nearly a quarter of
democrats 24
say they're not friends with anyone who
holds very different political views
from them a 14-point rise
from when yougov asked the same question
in september 2016.
independents show an 8 point increase
while republicans have not changed
significantly in the last four years
do you see this stuff is moving in a bad
direction it's not getting better
it's getting worse
now why is it getting worse well i think
one of the reasons is social media
because social media kind of
keeps people in these little bubbles i
think cable news is part of the problem
everyone says oh you know there's
diversity of thought on k no there's not
come on man there's not
there's not there's an agenda we all
know every cable news network has one
and then there's you know you're four
conservatives or you're one liberal or
you're four liberals or what you know
how this works right
you know how it works it's not a real
conversation there's no time even if
they wanted to have it there's no time
with the restrictions there
so this stuff is moving in a direction
that we don't want it to move in people
are getting more afraid to speak their
minds people are less inclined to
to become friends with or to converse
with or to reach out to someone of of a
different political opinion
that's all bad
one of the reasons that i'm here
doing this
is because when i went on pbd and
patrick knows this
we had a conversation
we had a real conversation we didn't
agree on everything adam and i don't
agree a lot we know that
but it felt like a real moment in a real
exchange i walked away from that
experience and i said
we need to do this more
meaning
yes us as a team but
in the country i need to do it more at
home i need to do it more with friends
and my hope is that people will receive
it well although based on my instagram
experience this past weekend i don't
know
and i'm curious before we you know shift
a little bit
tyler because you're in a younger
bracket than i am
do you see this among people your age is
it bad is there a resistance to having
conversations with people who see the
world differently or is this something
that's manifested in an older generation
more in your opinion no i think it's
certainly both i have family members who
i'm terrified to have conversations with
because
they
they can't have their opinions changed
they're very set in their ways it's like
yeah i'll have the conversation but i
know that ultimately it's not going to
go anywhere it's just going to be a
fight as opposed to a discussion i'm
listen i'm all for having discussion
have an open mind have your opinions
changed i'm not gonna sit there and
fight with you but like you say on
instagram
all the times i see people saying if you
voted for trump if you're a conservative
if you're this that and the other just
unfriend me don't follow me don't talk
to me don't nothing and it really goes
to show how i mean maybe this is obvious
but it goes to show just how pervasive
human nature is like we thought we could
get past this tribalism right we thought
we could all come together be a
community work together talk with each
other and
you you can it just ultimately reverts
back to tribalism and it's going to be
interesting to see how we move past it
if we can and it also showcases you're
right like our weaknesses as human
beings right we we all have this chip
sometimes where it's a little bit of an
internal fight you're like oh i can't
believe they're saying that believe me
believe me i
struggled a lot
after that incident on the view i
struggled a lot because i felt like i
was now in a position where i had always
been that person of like let's sit at
the table let's talk it out but i felt
like if the other side had a chance to
bury me
forget it they would
i actually felt like when it came to a
matter i mean something so simple as me
just saying hey my doctor says this
isn't for me
end of story
simple fact that i repeated from the cdc
the backs can get spread covered so the
mandates are unjustified that should
have just been a simple debate
but
i felt at that moment like wow they'll
bury me without blinking
so i need to come out and be like them
there was a moment i had where i was
like i need to be like that and then i
caught myself and i said oh no i'm never
gonna do that
i'm never going to do that and and the
reason was
i was really lucky because sitting in
front of me on every one of those
appearances that i did including that
one and i'll never forget that day is
that little picture of my cover of my
book with me and my little boy and i
looked at that kid's smile and i said
i have
some bigger job to do than that moment
on the view i need to teach my kid that
you walk away from that and you're still
somebody who wants to sit and have a
conversation but it took a lot
it took a lot so i don't know what that
moment's going to be tyler but for the
next generation i have to hope that the
people listening in their 20s
in their you know if you're in high
school you're in college whatever you
are that you say to yourself i will miss
out on a wealth of wonderful people and
wonderful opportunities if i create a
bubble for myself and i will also miss
out on becoming a whole person because
you're going to be a quarter of a person
in there getting pat on the back for
every opinion oh yeah i'm right all the
time no you need someone to say have you
thought about the fact that you might be
wrong that's what builds a human being
that's what turns a little person uh a
toddler
uh an infant into an adult one day if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]